hey y'all this ain't Miley Cyrus Taffy
teeners moved me into the teeners Tower
and they're saying I can't leave unless
I read this script
so here we go
Taffy teeners is for teens and tweeners
queens and streamers sheens and
screamers jeans and dreamers so eat a
pound of Taffy teeners and premier
greeners
puppy teeners is not responsible for
lesions that may form on your tongue as
a result of enjoying Taffy teeners enjoy
Taffy teeners responsibly and always I
repeat always where the Taffy teeners
enjoy and hat while enjoying Taffy
teeners
can I get out of the teener's tower now
anyway y'all are rocking out with dudesy